The Toto Apricot is a fancy toilet with an
automatic lifting seat, bidet, and deodorizer,
and some models even feature an mp3 player...
What The Fak.
The Facts And Knowledge on Future Toilets.
The
Kohler Numi Bidet Toilet features a foot warmer,
heated seat, and built-in music system.
It's all controlled with a touch screen remote
and runs for about $6,300 dollars.
The Clean Seat is a hygienic way to cover
a public toilet seat in paper by automatically
pulling down and placing it for you, and disposing
of it.
And this CWS rotating seat self-cleans by
spinning the entire thing through this module
that sanitizes and dries it before retracting
back into place.
For high-tech toilet privacy, these stalls
at Bar 89 in New York City fog up when they're
occupied.
Here's a homemade Steampunk toilet with antique
gauges and even a laser-pointing mechanism.
The Ultimate Clean Toilet concept features
a two-in-one toilet that swivels into a urinal.
It also self-santizes with steam and UV.
The all-in-one concept goes one step further
by integrating a sink that uses water runoff
to fill the tank and flush the toilet.
However, these innovative concepts still rely
on old flush technology.
So, the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
is funding research to re-invent the toilet,
because 40% of the world still lives without
a safe way to remove their excrement, and
we're using water and sewer technology that's
basically two hundred years old.
They aim to create low-cost toilets that safely
recycle the waste.
Virginia Gardiner created this plumbing-free
toilet that's literally made out of poop.
Her waterless toilet design seals the waste
in a cartidge which is then transported to
an anaerobic digester that recycles the methane
gas.
Outdoor urinals are gaining popularity around
the world, including these in Sydney, Australia.
And now for a couple of bathroom myths:
Airplanes do not drop toilet waste from the
sky.
The waste is collected in a secure holding
tank that is emptied after it lands.
Leaks have been known to happen, which cause
the waste to freeze on the exterior of the
plane and fall off in clumps known as Blue
Ice.
But it's rare.
Water does not drain opposite directions depending
on the Hemisphere.
The Coriolis Effect does cause macroevents,
like hurricanes, to rotate clockwise in the
Southern Hemisphere and counterclockwise in
the Northern, but it's effect is insignificant
when it comes to microevents like bathwater
draining or toilet flushes.
I'm gonna leave you with this guy.
Who is he and what notable invention did he
develop?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
And, as always, thanks for watching.